[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
FRANK SCHILBACH: OK.
So let me sort of
just recap what
we discussed last
time fairly quickly,
and then I want to move
to empirical evidence
on a variety of settings.
We might not get through
all of the slides.
That's fine.
In that case, we'll just discuss
some of this in recitation.
So let me sort of recap
what Kahneman and Tversky,
in their 1979 article,
were proposing
based on a bunch of experiments
and empirical evidence
that they had collected.
So their theory, it was
called prospect theory
what they proposed.
Versions of prospect
theory is essentially
versions of reference dependent
utility, have been used
or used prominently
now in economics.
So the first thing
that they proposed
was, what matters, what
the carrier of utility is,
is changes rather than levels.
That's to say it doesn't matter
for you necessarily how warm it
is.
It matters kind of what's the
change of temperature compared
to yesterday.
It doesn't matter
that much how much
money people have in total.
It matters how much that
changes relative to what
they had previously.
More generally, what matters
for people is essentially
a certain consumption
or the like relative
to reference point as
opposed to in absolute terms.
Second, loss aversion, this is
losses loom larger than gains.
And we had some evidence of
that in the last lecture.
That's to say, if you lose
some money or some consumption
or anything else,
grades, et cetera,
a loss relative to
either your status
quo or to your expectation
looms larger, is more important,
hurts more than a gain
of the same magnitude
in the positive direction.
And number three, which
we talked about quickly,
is what's referred to as
diminishing sensitivity.
That is people are risk
averse in the gain domain,
but risk loving in
the loss domain.
That's to say, for example, if
you think about distance, time,
chance, and the like, going
from 0 to 1 or from 1 to 2
or from 2 to 3 is
more important for you
than going from, like, 100 to
101, 101 to 102, and so on.
Essentially, the
further you go away
from your status quo,
your reference point,
any marginal change
is diminishing, right?
And that's true for both
the gain domain and the loss
domain.
So these are sort of the
main three characteristics
related to what Kahneman-Tversky
called the value function.
We can think of this
as essentially version
of the utility function.
There's a fourth
characteristic, which
is probability weighting,
which we're not going
to talk about at least for now.
Are there any questions on
these three things so far?
OK.
So now, prospect theory is
then what Kahneman and Tversky
were proposing.
They were essentially
saying, instead of
having concave utility,
which I showed you last week,
instead your utility
function may look like this.
And what are sort of the
features of this utility
function?
What are the three key features
that I just showed you?
How are they showing up
in this function here?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: C minus
[INAUDIBLE] is the change?
FRANK SCHILBACH: Right.
So the carrier of the
utility function--
so what we have here is c and r.
c is like consumption.
That could be anything.
That could be apples.
That could be bananas.
That could be sort of how
much money people have
available to consume overall.
The carrier of the utility
function is not c itself.
It's c minus r, so it's c of
relative to some reference
point r.
That's exactly right.
And if r is the
status quo, if r is
how much we have right now
or the person has right now,
c minus r is the change
relative to the status quo.
Notice that r-- we're going to
talk about this a little bit--
could be also other things.
It doesn't have to be
necessarily the status quo.
It could be also people's
expectation or their goals
or their aspirations
for the future, right?
The key part is,
however, what matters
is-- this is the first
thing I was saying.
It's changes rather
than levels, changes
relative to some reference
point or consumption relative
to some reference point.
That's number one, yes.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: The
curve flattens out,
which is diminishing
sensitivity.
FRANK SCHILBACH: Exactly.
The curve flattens out
in both directions.
That's diminishing sensitivity.
It's essentially concave
in the gain domain,
in the domain where
c is larger than r.
And it's convex
in the loss domain
where c is smaller
than r, right?
And that's exactly the issue
that essentially the first,
the marginal change,
going from, say, 1 to 2
is relatively large compared
to a marginal change going
from 10 to 11.
That's both going in the right
direction in the gains domain
and the left direction
in the loss domain.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: For the loss
aversion, the left side
is steeper than the right side.
FRANK SCHILBACH: Exactly.
In particular, there's
a kink in this function.
When you look at 0, where c
equals r, the gain and loss
domain intersect, there we have
a kink in the value function,
in the utility function, which
essentially exactly is the loss
domain, the loss aversion which
is like going to the right
is less steep than
going to the left.
Put differently, if
you lose, if you're
sort of below the
reference point,
that's more painful than being
the same amount of units to be
above the reference point.
That's number two.
That's essentially
exactly the loss aversion.
So I just wrote
down all of that.
Again, let me repeat.
Carrier of the utility changes
relative to the reference
point--
excuse me-- rather than levels.
Second, there's loss aversion.
There's a kink at
0 in this function.
And three, there's
diminishing sensitivity,
which is concavity in gains
and convexity in losses.
Any questions on that?
Now, a key question here is--
I want to sort of flag this.
We're going to talk
about this a little bit
at the end of the lecture.
We're going to talk to this a
little bit in the next problem
set is kind of like how is the
reference point determined.
And does it matter?
As I said before, in
Kahneman-Tversky's work,
a lot of the reference
point is the status quo.
So they essentially
postulated the status quo is
what really matters originally.
I think people have moved toward
saying the reference point.
And this is what Koszegi and
Rabin and others have written
down in their models of
reference dependence utility
and recent more economics
work is what really matters
is expectation.
So what do you expect to
consume or to have and so on?
That matters.
That sometimes coincides
with the status quo.
For example, if
you have a house,
the status quo is
that you have a house.
You probably assume that you
have a house in the future.
These things coincide.
If you think about
wages, et cetera,
what seems to matter
often is not so much
what people's wages
are right now.
What matters is what
wage gains and so on do
they expect to
receive in the future.
And they evaluate their future,
their outcomes in the future,
not necessarily to the
current wage, but rather
what they expect they
would get in the future.
OK.
And so here's an example.
And you'll have some
problems set questions.
Again, this is a
problem set three--
which is not posted
yet, but will be--
of that kind, which is
you might have reference
dependent utility over--
this is just a very
simple example--
shirts and money.
So you have essentially
two different domains.
You have, essentially,
losses and gains over
both of those domains.
You have a reference
point, which is rs,
is how many shirts
you might have.
You have a reference point, rm,
how much money you might have.
Now, what's important
here is that,
essentially, when you
think about buying a shirt
or selling a shirt,
there's going
to be two dimensions which
you have to sort of consider.
And when you think
about the endowment
effect of [INAUDIBLE]
and so on, you
have to consider
not only the losses
and gains and shirts, but also
the losses and gains and money.
So that's to say, if you're
trying to buy something,
you're going to get
a gain in shirts
relative to the reference
point if it's unexpected.
But you'll also have
a loss in money.
Similarly, if you're
going to sell a shirt,
you're going to have a loss in
shirts, but a gain in money.
And these things then interact.
Now, what's the value function?
The value function,
as I said before,
is usually concave
in the gain domain
and convex in the last domain.
There's a kink at 0.
It's steeper on the
left than on the right.
Usually, we think the relative
slope is about 2, 2.5, OK?
So one version of that
would be this function
that I wrote down.
Again, there will
be some problem
set questions, et cetera,
sort of to clarify that.
But one key question
here is, then
what are the different domains?
And that's kind of a question
of mental accounting.
We'll get to this in the
second half of the course.
The question's
kind of like, what
are the different categories?
Do you have shirts?
Do you have pants, sweaters?
Or is it just for
clothes overall?
Or when you think about earnings
and consumption, et cetera,
is it daily consumption?
Is it weekly consumption?
Is it monthly consumption?
So there's lots of questions
on how to exactly specify
this utility function.
These questions are mostly
unanswered in the literature.
So for now, for us
in our purposes,
we're going to
essentially assume
there is a value
function given and then
sort of work with that.
Any questions on that?
OK, great.
So now, we're going
to talk about a number
of different applications.
We talked a little bit already
about the endowment effect
and about insurance.
I'm going to skip this.
There's some of this already in
recitation in the problem sets.
We're going to particularly
talk about labor supply
and employment
decisions, essentially
how much do people like to work.
And is effort or
people's work decisions,
are they reference dependent?
We're going to talk
about finances,
what was mentioned last time
already about investment
decisions.
When do people sell
and buy stocks?
We're going to
talk about housing.
When do people decide to sell or
buy a house and at what price?
We're going to talk about
sports, in particular marathon
running and golf.
There's some papers
on domestic violence
we're going to talk
very briefly about.
And then we talk a
little bit about firms.
How do firms think
about pricing and so on?
What is sort of
the market response
to reference dependence?
That's to say, given that we
know there's lots of reference
dependence in the
world, now, as a firm
or treating other people,
how should we think about,
how does that affect,
our own behavior
or how maybe firms
interact with us?
OK.
So let's start
with labor supply.
Let's start with a
very simple example.
Suppose there's a worker
in the following situation.
She can freely choose how many
hours she works every day.
And there are frequent temporary
changes in her hourly wage.
Now, there's different
relationships
between wages and hours per day.
You could always work
the same number of hours.
You could work more hours on
the days when wages are high.
Or you could work fewer hours
on days when the wages are high.
What does sort of
standard theory say?
What should you do?
Yes?
Two?
AUDIENCE: Two.
FRANK SCHILBACH: Why is that?
AUDIENCE: Because that maximizes
your expected value for time.
FRANK SCHILBACH: Right.
So if hours are effortful, you
usually don't like to work.
You should work
during the hours when
your payment is the largest.
That's right.
So what about option number one?
Why might option
number one be optimal?
So what you're saying
is exactly right.
It depends a little
bit on something else.
And what is that?
Why might you choose
number one anyway?
AUDIENCE: Habit-forming is nice.
FRANK SCHILBACH: Yeah, there
could be sort of habits,
exactly.
Or it could just be that
it's really effortful
to work 12 hours in one day.
Maybe there's kids at home, or
maybe it's just really tedious
to work.
At some point, you just want
to go home and do other stuff.
So it could just be that working
beyond, say, eight or nine
hours per day is
really tough to do.
So then you might
say, I'm always
going to work eight hours.
I'd love to work more,
but it's difficult to do.
So essentially,
it's just to say,
if the function of the effort as
a function of hours is convex,
then you might sort
of keep it the same.
Surely, what you
don't want to do
is number three,
working fewer hours
on days when wages are high
unless effort costs are
particularly high on those days.
So it could be that
it's really super hot.
Or it could be it's tedious
to work on those days.
And you might say, then
you don't want to do it.
But assuming that's
not the case,
you kind of want to avoid this.
Because for the same
number of hours,
you're going to make
less money overall.
And so here's a
concrete example.
Suppose wage is 5 hours
an hour on day one
and 10 hours a day on day two.
So there's three strategies.
You can work 8
hours on both days.
You can work 6 hours on day
one, 9 hours on day two,
or the opposite, 9 hours on
day one and 6 hours on day two.
So if you do that, you can sort
of calculate how much that is.
You can essentially work
8 hours on both days.
You get 120 hours.
You can work 6 hours
on days one and two,
which makes $120 as well.
Or you can essentially do the
opposite, which makes you $105.
This is what I was saying.
Option three doesn't
make a lot of sense
unless effort costs
are particularly
high on certain days
when the wages are high.
We're assuming
that away for now.
And so now option two--
and this is what you
were saying-- essentially
saves you an hour overall.
You work only 15 hours
instead of 16 hours.
And you make the
same amount of money.
Now, unless the ninth hour is
extremely costly for you to do,
you might not want to do that.
OK.
Now, why might you do
something else instead?
Or where does reference
dependence come in here?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I see on the
high wage day you make more
than the less wage day, so
I feel like stopping maybe.
FRANK SCHILBACH: And
why would you stop?
What's causing you to stop?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] wages
higher relative to [INAUDIBLE]..
FRANK SCHILBACH: Yeah.
Yes.
And so what are you evaluating?
Or what's the-- or what
happens, for example,
if you work only 6 hours
on a different day?
How much do you make on the
sixth hour day, I guess,
which would be $30, right?
And so what are you
comparing that to, I guess?
AUDIENCE: You're comparing
it to the actual money
you made at the end of the day.
FRANK SCHILBACH: Right.
But so suppose you,
on average, want
to make a certain
amount of money,
which is $50, $60 and so on.
Now, if on some days you make
a lot of money and on some day
you make very little
money, you might sort of
evaluate that separately
and say, on that day,
I'm essentially in
the loss domain.
I'm below my target or
below my expectation.
And so if you evaluate
your utility that way,
you might sort of not want that
because it feels essentially
you're below a
certain threshold.
It feels kind of like a loss
relative to your expectation
and so on when you might
be inclined to work
a lot of hours.
Instead, on the days when
you make a lot of money,
why might you stop?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: You
might have a target
that you expect to meet every
day to cover your expenses.
And if you feel like the work
[INAUDIBLE] reach that target,
you might [INAUDIBLE].
FRANK SCHILBACH: Right.
So if you target,
your reference point,
is essentially a
certain number, you
might reach that target
quickly because your wage
is pretty high on that day.
And once you reach
that target, you
might say, well,
now utility function
is relatively not
very steep anymore
relative to being
in the loss domain.
So it's flatter.
So then you might just
stop relatively soon
because, essentially, any
marginal earnings are not
really valuable for you anymore.
OK?
Any questions on
that or comments?
So why do we want the wage
changes to be temporary here?
What's an issue here
when you sort of try
to look at this in the data?
Suppose I had
persistent wage changes.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So you can have
a frame of reference?
FRANK SCHILBACH: Yeah.
You want to kind of keep
the reference constant.
So in some sense, if wage
changes are permanent,
then you get essentially
income effects.
You'll be a lot richer overall.
If they're only
temporary, essentially,
you can sort of argue that,
essentially, your expectation
should be the same.
And once you reach, once
you have a lot more money,
the neoclassical
model should actually
say that there should
be income affects.
Essentially, the
neoclassical model says,
you should essentially aggregate
all of your income and say,
it doesn't really matter
whether you earn it
on Monday, or Tuesday,
Wednesday, or Thursday.
You should look at how much
are you earning overall
depending whether you
earn sufficiently much,
you're going to work
fewer or more hours.
Now, if you earn a lot, because
your wages doubles or whatever,
you might actually
work few hours
not because you reach a
reference point on a given day.
It's just because
you got a lot richer,
and then you decide
it's not worth
for you to work that much.
So we're kind of
trying to avoid that.
We're trying to have only
temporary changes, which
is to say, for given wealth
overall on any given day,
it shouldn't matter
whether you earn the money
on Monday or on Tuesday.
So essentially, if
the wage happens
to be really high
on Tuesday, you
should be working more,
earning more, on Tuesday
as opposed to on Monday.
Now, what I was saying is, if
you're reference dependent,
you might actually
care about this.
You might care about on Monday
you didn't reach your target.
Therefore, you
want to work more.
On Tuesday, you reached
your target very quickly.
And you work less even
though the wage is actually
really high.
OK.
Now, strategy one
might be optimal even
in the neoclassical model
if effort costs are convex.
This is what I was
saying is, if it's really
sort of costly for you to
work 9 hours, you might say,
I always work 8 hours.
I want to have a certain
amount of money for my children
and so on.
So the extra hour, if that's
really, really painful,
you might not want to do that.
We don't think
that's necessarily
the case in so many situations.
The question is,
can we really say
that strategy three--
that's the strategy of doing
the opposite, of working
essentially a lot of hours
when wages are low and few
hours when wages are high.
Can we really say
it's a mistake?
Well, it depends on kind of
whether the effort costs are
correlated with wages.
So if cab drivers,
for example, make
really high wages on some days
and low wages on other days,
it could just be on low
wage day it's much less
effortful to drive around.
So you would do more hours.
It turns out, when you
actually ask cab drivers,
they actually prefer busy days.
They actually prefer it
when there are customers as
opposed to just driving
around and looking for people.
So we don't think
that's actually true.
But in principle, you would
have to sort think about that.
Now, there's a long literature
starting with Camerer et al.
On cab drivers.
A lot of that
essentially is pre-Uber,
like collecting trip
shifts from cab drivers.
Now, there's lots
of like Uber data
that's essentially much
more powerful in some ways.
So there will be probably more
papers using Uber and Lyft,
et cetera, data on that.
But what Camerer et
al. did at the time
was they essentially
looked at typical cab
drivers that rent their cab
for 12 hour periods for a fixed
fee.
And within this 12
hour window, a driver
can choose their hours freely.
So you just get your
cab that's not yours.
You rent it for the day.
And then you can essentially
choose how many hours
you want to work.
And their wages, how much money
they make in any given hour,
varies by a lot.
The weather varies, the
subway breakdowns, conferences
and so on and so forth.
There's lots of variation
in how much money you
make on a given day.
So then they have trip
sheets that look at how long
cab drivers work and
their overall earnings.
And so they can essentially
back out the wages from each day
and then look at like how
much do people work on days
when wages are high versus
days when wages are low.
And then they essentially
find the basic finding.
And that's a finding that's
sort of been contested
in the literature many people
have found or confirmed
subsequently.
And others have not, but
I think eventually people
have sort of settled on this.
Hours are negatively
correlated with wages.
So when wages in particular
are unexpectedly high,
cab drivers tend to
work fewer hours.
And again, this is not
for permanent changes,
but for transitory changes.
Surprisingly, on a given
day people get more money,
then drivers work few hours.
And that's very hard to explain
for the neoclassical model.
Because, essentially,
you shouldn't care about
whether you make the money
on Monday, on Tuesday.
As I said, you should care about
how much money you make overall
and how many hours you work.
And so it's very
hard to explain this.
And sort of the explanation that
Camerer et al. and others were
testing or arguing
is essentially
this has to do with
reference dependence.
And so what's being evaluated
in a reference dependent way?
Or how do we think about this?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
FRANK SCHILBACH: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: How did they
rule out the possibility
that maybe there is
reverse causality maybe
on a day where none
of the cab drivers
want to work that much
because it's supply and demand
that they just go on?
FRANK SCHILBACH: So that's
to say effort costs are high.
So usually, it's to
do with other drivers.
So let me actually
get through-- so let
me defer this for one second.
I have a slide on confounds.
And then we can see the
rest of your question
and then get back to that.
But that's a good question.
So what is being evaluated
in reference-dependent way?
What are people
looking at in terms
of where's the reference
point in the evaluation here?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I guess, if you're
a cab driver, you kind of say,
oh, I want to make
this much money today.
And then you just
kind of work until you
feel like you've made enough,
and then you just stop.
FRANK SCHILBACH: Right, exactly.
You have to pay your
fixed fee for the day
or for the month or whatever.
But there's an implicit
fixed fee for the day.
So you kind of want to make
at least that much money
to make not a loss.
You probably have some positive
target in some way in saying,
like, I want to make
pay back for my fee plus
you want to make some
money for the day and minus
sort of expenses.
And once you reach that target,
you are in the gain domain.
Below that, you are in
the loss domain, right?
And so the daily
income essentially--
and that's essentially sort
of money after paying back
the fee, but you
could also get--
it's essentially
what's being evaluated
in the reference-dependent way.
What's the reference
point is some daily target
that you have.
Often, it's expectation
and so on and sort of,
essentially, how much
you think you will make.
And then what's the feature
of the value function
that explains the phenomenon?
Well, it's loss aversion.
If you're falling short
of the target, essentially
your marginal utility--
when you drive another
hour or another trip,
the marginal utility that you
get, since the value function
is very steep below the target--
is very high.
Once you reach the
target, it's very flat.
And then essentially
you tend to stop.
Does that make sense?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
FRANK SCHILBACH: OK, great.
So the main takeaway
is, so if drivers often
stop at their daily
income target,
driver with a higher wage
reach their targets faster.
And they work fewer hours.
Again, that's variation
within drivers across days.
And sort of there's lots of
subsequent work and debate
regarding this finding.
The debate is still ongoing.
For example, one recent
paper looks at tips
that drivers get unexpectedly.
So sometimes drivers get large
tips, sometimes get small tips.
It depends a lot when in the
day they receive the tip,
if they receive it
really early versus late,
if they sort of get
to their target.
And essentially,
the target seems
to be adjusting over time.
But overall-- and this is
sort of getting a little bit
at your question--
we think it's not sort
of aggregate supply.
But the debate is still ongoing.
But overall, we sort of think
that lots of labor supply
decisions, when people
have daily decisions of how
many hours to work
and their wages vary,
depend on reference points
and might sort of potentially
be at least suboptimal.
Or put differently, people
could work fewer hours
and try to sort of adjust
their overall amounts.
For a while, I did this.
You can ask your
Uber and Lyft drivers
what they're doing
and so on and see
whether they're a
reference-dependent driver,
sort of where they have
reference-dependent
preferences.
Now, what are sort of potential
alternative hypotheses?
One question, one issue, could
be liquidity constraints.
This is, for example, if you
just don't have enough cash.
If you have to pay back
your fee for the day
or for the next day, you might
want to not work only very
few hours on a given day.
It turns out that drivers
who own their own medallion
exhibit the same patterns.
There could be
things like fatigue.
Let's just say it's really
tedious to work on certain days
when wages are high.
We don't think that's going
on in part because drivers
themselves, they say,
it's actually easier
to drive with more passengers.
Again, recent papers,
in fact, can also
control for this and so on.
So we don't think
it's actually fatigue.
And this is, I think,
what you're saying.
The last one is
unobserved shocks, so some
shocks that affect all drivers'
labor supply at the same time.
Example, there are some days in
which all drivers get the flu.
Fewer drivers will work.
And those who will
work work fewer hours.
And those who work
get higher wages.
That's a little bit trickier
for them to rule out.
In part, there's other papers,
other studies afterwards,
that sort of try to get at this.
Usually, yeah, for this specific
data, that's hard to do.
I think for the other data where
people have essentially not
just daily--
so this is essentially
trip sheets.
So what they're using mostly
is daily wages overall.
They don't even have the wage.
They only have the overall
earnings and then the hours.
And then they sort
of compute the wage
dividing the two, which
causes some other trouble.
But once you have
Uber data, once you
have specific trips and
particular also tips
and so on, you can look
at, on a given day when
I get a high tip
versus a low tip,
you can predict,
essentially, how much I'm
going to earn on a given day.
So suppose you
predict that I'm going
to earn $100 in a given day.
Now, I have, say, $50 or $60.
Now, I get a large trip
and a tip and so on that
gets me over that threshold.
You can look at whether I stop.
You can look at the
exact same thing.
When I have only $20 and I get a
large tip, do I stop and so on?
So you can essentially
control for all of that
and then do within
driver comparisons,
like for trips that happen
to be large or small that you
happen to get in a given hour.
And then you can sort of deal
with overall market conditions.
I think even better,
in the future,
there will be sort
of experiments
and so on where you can look
at when Uber and Lyft try
to incentivize their
workers and so just,
say, essentially, sometimes pay
people more and less randomly,
sort of explicitly
randomly, because they
want to kind of learn about
how to best incentivize
their drivers.
And then you can
control for everything
because it's explicitly random
whether a certain driver gets
high versus low wages
or sort of trip fares.
Yeah.
OK.
Any questions on
the labor supply?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I'm a bit confused
about the unobserved shock.
Because if you get
a really large tip,
that doesn't necessarily predict
that the rest of the day you'd
have higher wages
if you kept working.
[INAUDIBLE] you get
this really high tip,
and then you would be like,
oh, today's a lucky day.
I can stop early.
But if I have worked
more this day,
I wouldn't necessarily be making
continuously more than normal.
FRANK SCHILBACH: Right.
So in the unobserved, in
the large tip example,
the assumption is exactly--
or what they show in the paper.
This is subsequent work,
not this specific work.
What they exactly show
in this type of paper,
these are sort of random events.
In a sense, it's
precisely not predictive
of your future earnings.
It's random.
Now, one interpretation
that you have is to say,
well, it could be that you
kind of have some expectations
about your future earnings.
They could be
particularly high or low.
It's like, I got my lucky
day and so on and so forth.
That is hard to rule out.
In some sense, if you had
rational expectations,
that's hard to explain for
the neoclassical model.
What's harder to rule
out is to say, you know,
I now think I got my
lucky draw for the day.
And that's it.
And I'm not going to get
any lucky draw again.
Let's just call it a day.
That is hard to rule out.
But what is hard to explain
for the neoclassical model--
I think we can sort
of reject-- is to say,
if you just think
this is a shock, which
really in reality it is
and you just happened
to get a bunch of money on
a given day just randomly,
then the reference-dependent
model can sort of
explain why you stop early.
Because it just gets you
over the reference point.
The neoclassical
model should just say,
depends on essentially
how many hours
you want to work on a given day.
It's nothing to
do with a target.
Because essentially,
again, it doesn't
matter whether you
make money on Monday,
or Tuesday, or Wednesday.
You should just care about
the overall amount of money
that you make overall.
But that's a good question.
OK.
So now, a second paper
is on the housing market.
So what is the natural reference
point for housing market?
Or how do we think
about housing prices?
Or how do you think about--
I guess a few of you
will own a house.
But if you owned
a house, how would
you think about selling a house?
What is an actual
reference point?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Whatever it was
before or how [? changes ?]
[INAUDIBLE].
FRANK SCHILBACH:
Yeah, so exactly.
So the previous
purchase price, it
turns out it's a very, very
salient thing for owners.
People really know how much
they paid for their house.
It's a huge expense
in their life.
They really remember it
was like 300,00, 500,000,
a million, et cetera.
They know exactly
how much they paid.
And when you even ask people,
the majority of people
know exactly how much
they paid for their home.
Now, one claim is
that loss aversion
makes people unwilling to
sell their houses at a loss.
And so what they would then
do is they ask essentially
for higher prices, if a loss,
relative to their purchase
price.
And let me just show you
exactly what I mean by that.
Genesove and Mayer have
Boston condominium data
from 1992 in 1997.
Luckily for them, there's lots
of variation or fluctuations
in the housing market
during that time.
So the housing
market went up a lot,
and then it went down a
lot and went up a lot.
Now, suppose you have two
sellers, A and B, who both want
to sell their home in 1994.
Now, what we can do is we
can look at these two people.
Suppose they have
very similar houses
based on observable
characteristics and location
and so on and so forth.
So once they have really
comparable houses,
we can all look at seller A,
purchased their home really
early on, in 1989.
That person happens to be
quite unlucky because they just
bought the house really
at the peak of, I guess,
the housing boom at the time.
Or seller number B, who
purchased in 1991, that person
was relatively lucky.
They bought
essentially at a time
when the housing market was
relatively low and appreciated
quite a bit.
So now, we can look at these
two people and ask the question,
is seller A or seller B more
likely to sell their house?
And the hypothesis is
that seller A will sort of
view this as a loss.
This seller will essentially
just say I'm losing money here.
I don't want to sell.
And that seller
might essentially
ask for a higher
listing price and wants
make more money for this
house because they don't want
to make a loss on that sale.
Well, seller B says, I'm
actually gaining money anyway.
So let's just sort of
post whatever you think
is actually the
expected market price.
I might be happy to sell
at a lower price compared
to seller A.
OK.
So one thing we can look at
essentially are listing prices.
How much do people
want for the houses?
The second thing they can look
at is actual sales prices.
Are you now selling this
at a higher or lower price?
And number three, we
can look at how long
is the house on the market.
How long does it
actually take to sell it?
That's a quite
costly thing to do
to have your house on the
market for quite a while
because, essentially, often
people then don't already
move somewhere else.
Or they can't really
live in the house
because they have to sort
of show it and make it
available for
showings and so on.
So it's a costly thing to do.
You really don't want to
have your house on the market
for several months.
But is sort of the
broad idea clear
of what we're trying to do?
OK.
So what predictions
do we want to test?
We want to test whether
house owners are
reluctant to sell their house
when the current market price
is below the purchase price.
So the ideal specification
is essentially the following.
We look at the list price
on the left-hand side.
And then we are going to run a
regression that looks at some
constant-- that's just kind
of time trends, et cetera--
plus a beta, which is the
coefficient of interest.
Or one coefficient of interest
is of the actual market price.
How much is the thing worth?
And then delta on the loss is
how much do you lose relative
to your purchase price.
Now, if people were not
reference-dependent,
what should we find?
Or what would be
the predictions?
The neoclassical model,
what should we find here?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: We should find
that delta 0 [INAUDIBLE]??
FRANK SCHILBACH: Exactly.
Delta should not matter.
It shouldn't matter how much you
lost or gained in that house.
What should matter is what
is the actual market value.
You should essentially try
to be willing to sell it not.
Beta could be-- it
doesn't have to be 1.
It could be everybody pays
above the actual market.
There's some housing
bubble or whatever.
Beta could be 1.1 or
whatever you might be.
That depends on, essentially,
sort of aggregate conditions
and so on.
But delta really
should not matter.
When I'm trying to
sell you a house,
you should ask, what's
the actual market value?
And I should,
essentially, then based
on that, put it on a market
on that listing price.
But what might be the case is
that the loss actually matters.
Now, one problem here is that
the actual market value is not
observable, right?
So I don't actually know
what the market value
is because that's endogenous.
That's part of the transaction.
So what can I do instead?
Or how do I do this?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: By asking people,
would you take this trade?
And then see what they say.
[INAUDIBLE]
FRANK SCHILBACH: Right.
So you can look at actually
the market outcome overall.
You can look at who
buys it and what's
the actual purchase price.
Now, that might also be
endogenous to the listing
price, right?
So if you think you know that
people who are loss averse
are listing their houses
too high relatively compared
to what the market
value actually is,
it might actually be
sold at a higher price.
So that's hard to interpret.
It could just be that, if you
list it at a very high price
and wait for a long time, you
also sell it at a higher price.
But it doesn't mean that that's
actually worth that much.
It just means that you happen
to find a buyer who happens
to be willing to pay a lot.
And that's more likely when
you wait for a long time, which
is not necessarily optimal,
because it's actually
quite costly to do that.
But you're saying something
else which is asking them
about what they think.
But what are the characteristics
that we could look at?
Or what data could we look at?
If you had Zillow data or
data on essentially a bunch
of these apps where
you can look at houses,
what data could you get?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: You'd
look at the houses
in the neighborhood, similar
houses that sold recently.
FRANK SCHILBACH: Exactly.
What Redfin and
Zillow, et cetera,
do these days is
essentially they
have these algorithms that try
to predict the actual market
sales price.
And what they tend
to do essentially
is look at, exactly as
you say, surrounding
houses that are similar
in some characteristics.
They look at the square footage.
They look at the number of
bathrooms and rooms in general.
They look at sort of location
and so on and so forth.
And then you can
predict how much--
and sort of they look at all
the time trends and so on.
How much is the
actual market value?
But essentially, fundamentally,
it's a prediction exercise.
You can try to predict
what the actual value is.
And that's exactly what
Genesove and Mayer do.
They do some more
fancy things that
try to get it other unobservable
characteristics and so on.
But the essence of this is
exactly the prediction exercise
where they say, let's just
look at the characteristics
of this house.
Let's try to predict what
the market value is and then
look at the loss,
which is essentially
the difference between
the previous selling
price and the
expected selling price
truncated from 0 because,
otherwise, it's a gain.
And then we can look
at does it really
seem that, when people
are in the loss domain,
when their loss is positive,
are they now selling their house
or trying to sell their
house at a higher price?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: How do you
account for something
like recent renovations
since the last listing
and relative to any
other similar units
or houses or [INAUDIBLE]
[? nearby ?] [INAUDIBLE]??
FRANK SCHILBACH: Right.
So that's tricky to do.
And I don't think they
have this in their data.
So what you'd have
to assume here,
and that's perhaps
reasonable, is
to say that when you look
at sort of this picture
that seller A and
seller B did not
do differential
renovation depending
on when they bought the house.
Right?
So if you said, it's fine if
people have done renovations.
For example, this
is what I was saying
about the beta on the
actual market value.
If you systematically
underestimate or overestimate
how much people renovate and so
on, or maybe the housing market
is really hot or
whatever, that's OK.
The main issue is that can't be
correlated with the loss here.
So if it's the case that people
who lost a bunch of money
in terms of their housing
prices sort of tanked,
if those people have
done more or less
renovations, then you're in
trouble with your estimates.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Is the expected
selling price the estimation
of actual [? work ?] value?
FRANK SCHILBACH: Correct.
AUDIENCE: OK.
FRANK SCHILBACH: Yes.
So now, what Genesove
and Mayer find
is-- and there's
more detail to that.
But essentially, the
main finding is--
and that's a fairly solid one,
there's a bunch of different
specifications--
a 10% increase in
a prospective loss.
So if this loss
coefficient, the difference
between the expected selling
price and the purchase price,
if that's 10% higher, then
essentially the list price
is 2.5% to 3.5% higher.
So people list the price,
the house, at a higher price.
If the house is
at a loss compared
to a similar house
who's not at a loss
or who's in the gain
domain, these effects
then translate into higher
sales prices and a lower hazard
rate of sale.
That's to say people actually
sell it at a higher price.
So in fact, it's hard to say
here what's optimal versus not.
It could be that,
overall, people are like,
it's actually a
good thing to do.
That depends a lot on,
essentially, your opportunity
costs of money in
terms how costly is it
for you to keep the house
on the market for a while.
But essentially, people have
a lower hazard right of sale.
That's to say it just takes them
a lot longer to sell the house.
That tends to be
very costly to do.
But if you just otherwise would
have your money in the bank
and you have another
place to stay
and you don't really care,
maybe then that's fine.
But we surely have real
effects in terms of people
list their houses
at higher prices.
People sell them at
somewhat higher prices.
And people also keep them
longer on the market.
OK.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Is this
the same analysis
if it's gains on the
value of the house?
FRANK SCHILBACH: So
essentially, what we're doing
is we implicitly comparing
losses versus gains, right?
So the gains here would be
in the actual market value
already as it is.
But essentially, what
you're implicitly doing is,
when comparing implicitly,
this is what I was saying here.
When you look at this picture,
implicitly what we're doing
is we look at people who are
losing money compared to people
who are gaining money.
And explicitly or
implicitly, we're
asking, is the
increase and the gain
sort of predictive of that--
sorry, the increase in
the losses predictive
of your listing price?
Now, it's hard to do this
at the same time for gains
because, essentially, an
increase in the market price
overall that's
sort of collinear.
In [INAUDIBLE],, essentially
that's hard to separate.
You could do the same
analysis, and you
wouldn't find that
for the gains in part
because essentially
explicitly what we're doing
is incurring losses to gains.
OK.
So then there is another
piece of evidence
that sort of tells us
perhaps this is not optimal.
If you look at people who
are owner-occupied compared
to investors-- so
there are people who
essentially invest in houses.
And they sell houses.
And they sell lots
of houses over time.
Those people have much
lower endowment effect,
if you want, for houses.
So they exhibit this
behavior a lot less.
But people who live
in that house, who
bought that house,
for them it's mostly
the only house they live in.
It's the main purchase
that they have.
For them, it's essentially
their house for which
they don't want to make losses.
For them, these effects
are twice as large
compared to the investors.
And that's perhaps some
evidence that this is not
optimal behavior
in a sense of sort
of the professional investors.
They presumably know pretty
well how to price their houses.
So if they do this
behavior less,
presumably that's
a sign that there's
some form of a
mistake here going on.
Second, there's some evidence--
and John List has some work
on this overall--
to say that experience
can mitigate
reference dependent effects.
Essentially, if you
do a lot of trading,
if you sell a lot
of houses and so on,
then you might still
feel losses and gains,
but you might sort of have a
lot more experience with this.
You kind of know that this
is happening sometimes.
And you might be less prone
to these types of effects
because you kind of know that
you shouldn't be doing this.
You shouldn't sort of have your
feelings of losses and gains
get in the way of
making profits.
So there are some
people who would
argue that this is very
much consistent with markets
over time or
exposures to markets
and several predictions.
Experience makes some of
these effects go away.
And John List has
some separate evidence
on this on traders
of cards and so on.
OK.
So now, next, we're going
to talk a little bit
about finance and stocks.
So interestingly-- yeah.
AUDIENCE: Sorry, on
the previous study,
why [? is it ?] said
reference-dependent and not
some informational effect,
that I'm a home owner
and I think that my house
is worth this amount.
And I just [INAUDIBLE]
[? anchored ?]
to believing that
that's the amount.
FRANK SCHILBACH: Right.
So one thing you
could say is that--
so what you always have
to make the argument
is people who are at losses
compared to who are at gains.
So you look at our
investor A and B.
They might have additional
information on how much
the house is worth.
So it could be, for
example, that seller A
knows a lot about this house.
It's very beautiful and so
much light and this and that.
And, therefore, they paid a lot.
Therefore, they have
private information
that it's worth a lot.
Therefore, they list it
at a really high price.
So there are some specification
here that-- look at this.
What you see is this is
columns two, four, and six,
which is the residual
from the last sales price.
What is that?
That's essentially the
difference between at the time
when previously
the house was sold,
what was the prediction
of the market price then,
and how much was it sold.
So it's kind of like, how much
did you overpay, if you want,
relative to what we
expected at the time?
Presumably, that's
reflective and, again,
using the same
prediction method.
So if you thought,
you know, it's
really beautiful and lots of
windows and this and that, lots
of light, and really
quiet and so on,
if you overpaid
at the time, that
should then sort of be
predictive of the listing
price.
And sort of controlling for that
then should make this go away.
What you see, however, there's
some of that perhaps going on.
If you compare, for example,
columns one and two,
you see that the effect
goes down a little bit.
But it's still
there quite a bit.
This is why I was
saying 25% to 35%.
That is exactly right.
That's a big concern.
And there's a bunch
of sort of robustness,
et cetera, checks in
this specific study.
But that's exactly right.
There could be sort of
unobservable information
that the owner might have
about the house that is not
in Zillow or in
any sort of Redfin,
et cetera, predictions that's
available for the public.
That's a great question, but
I think it's, to the extent
that that takes care of
it, sort of the authors
have thought about that.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: On the
following slide,
when you talk about
the differences,
how do you control
for the selection bias
about the people that may be the
ones repeatedly selling houses
exhibit this less
and, therefore, stay
in the market versus a change
in those individuals' behavior?
FRANK SCHILBACH: Right.
That's a great question.
So the question you're asking
is essentially to say--
and it's, in fact, a
great sort of segue
into behavioral finance,
which is to say,
suppose there are some people
who are really sophisticated.
They don't have certain
behavioral biases.
Maybe they're not loss averse.
That makes you a
better investor, say.
And, therefore, you stay
in the market overall.
I think, from this
observation that I have here,
I cannot tell you is it
experience or is it selection.
So the question kind of is,
when people are investors,
do the effects of
reference-dependence of gains
and losses go away over time?
Essentially, maybe the
first, second, third time
they feel really a loss in terms
of making a bad investment.
But in house number 20, I'm
just like, that's as usual.
And I shouldn't sort of
really care very much.
Is it that this goes away?
Or is it that the people
who are particularly
loss averse and
sort of essentially
engage in this type
of behavior in terms
of listing too high
of a price for losses,
these are sort of bad investor
in the housing markets?
And they sort of are essentially
driven out of the market.
So that specific
setting I don't think we
can necessarily
account for that.
I think in the
studies by John List,
it's very much people argue
it's about experience.
But again, there also
some part could also
be selection I think.
So I think, in some
sense, either way
I think the evidence that
the investors are doing
this behavior less sort
of tells us something
about this is probably
not at least financially
optimal for you to engage
in this type of behavior.
It might be privately optimal.
In some sense, if
you really feel
at selling your
house at a loss, you
should probably list
it at a higher price
because that sort of
limits your losses.
That's just what a utility
function looks like.
It's not necessarily
suboptimal in the sense
of how you feel afterwards.
It might be suboptimal in terms
of how much money you make
or how much money you have
eventually on how much
you pay for keeping
your house on the market
and so on for an
extended period of time.
OK.
So did that answer
your question?
Yeah, OK.
So behavioral finance
is an interesting field
because, for quite
a while, economists
thought that sort of
neoclassical assumptions
are, in fact, most likely to
hold in financial markets.
And why is that?
And some of this already
I mentioned, but why
are financial
markets particular--
why might one think
that financial markets
are particularly efficient?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Well, you might
think that financial markets
are very competitive.
And so it's actually
the ones who
can get rid of their behavioral
biases that benefit the most
and stay within
financial market.
FRANK SCHILBACH: Exactly.
So it's very much sort of the
Chicago economics assumption
is to say, so financial markets
are extremely competitive.
If I'm an investor who has
various behavioral biases,
presumably I'm going
to lose some money one
way or the other.
Well, if markets are
really competitive,
in the long run I cannot stay
in this market without sort
of being driven out.
So essentially,
the market favors
sort of results-oriented,
rational, and selfish behavior.
So people who are not rational
and so on and so forth
will be eliminated from
the market eventually.
There's two parts to that.
That's true across firms.
That's to say there
are some firms
sort of better than others.
But also, within a
firm, if I'm an investor
and I'm sort of advising
clients and the like-- and
I'm sort of not
very good at this.
And essentially, I have
certain people biases
that are not optimal in terms
of making money for people.
Presumably, I will
not be promoted.
Presumably, I will be driven
out of or fired from the company
eventually.
So surprisingly,
in fact, finance
became one of the most
influential and most fruitful
applications of the
psychology in economics
of behavioral economics.
There's lots and lots of
work in behavioral finance.
The reason being
perhaps not necessarily
because people are--
so some people are
presumably driven out
of the market, but
surely not everyone.
But in particular, because there
is a great data in finance.
There's lots and lots of
daily data in terms of things
that you should
be doing compared
to what models would say.
So it's a really
great way of being
able to test models
or test essentially
predictions of the neoclassical
model or behavioral theories
and so on.
So that's why behavioral finance
has been very influential
because there's so much
data available for people
to, in fact, test theories.
And then why is it that people
are not entirely driven out?
I think often the case is
that, even if you're right,
for example, even if you're
right that you can predict--
and if you watch some movies
on the financial crisis
and so on, even if you're
right about in the long run
the market is going to
tank, well, actually it's
going to take a lot of money.
And often, if
everybody is wrong,
prices will go up
for quite a while.
So it's not actually
clear that, at least
in the short, medium run, we'll
be driven out of the market
quickly.
But that's sort of
a separate topic.
OK.
So now, one reason
why or one way
in which reference-dependent
behavior might
be important in
finance is people
might be differentially likely
to sell winners and hold
on to losers, financial stocks.
That was mentioned
last time as well.
So what Terry Odean did in
1997 is he had, in fact,
brokerage accounts from
the nationwide brokerage
house, which had all trades
and prices for, I guess, '87
to '93.
In some sense-- a little bit
old fashioned in a sense of you
shouldn't be an individual
trading and so on.
You should just hold the
stock market or the S&P 500
or some index funds and so on.
Here, these are people
who hold individual stocks
and sell and buy
them one by one.
And so during each trading
day, then what Odean can do
is he can look at, evaluate,
each stock in the portfolio
and look at this is a loss
relative to the purchase price.
So you can look at, essentially,
the portfolio and say there's
losers and winners.
He only has data
on trading days.
So you can look at are
they losers and winners
when they're being sold.
And he can look at then at
realized gains and realized
losses.
So if you sell a stock
and it's essentially
above the purchase price,
he calls it a realized loss.
Sorry, if it's a losing
stock, it's sold.
It's a realized loss.
It's below the purchase price.
If it's above the
purchase price,
it's going to be
a realized gain.
Now, one thing you
could do is compare
the number of realized losses
to the number of realized gains.
Does that work, or is
that reference-dependent?
So what did we learn from that?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
people [INAUDIBLE]
people won't want to
[INAUDIBLE] are losing stock
because they're comparing to the
price they bought [INAUDIBLE]..
FRANK SCHILBACH: Right.
So I could look at
the realized gains
and the number of realized
gains and the number of realized
losses.
But what's the
problem with that?
That's exactly right, but
what's the underlying,
what's the problem
with this approach?
How does this depend on the
stock market going up and down?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: You're not looking
at the magnitude of those gains
or losses?
FRANK SCHILBACH: Yeah.
So that's a separate issue.
You could look at the
magnitudes themselves.
And you could look at,
depending on where you are,
how does that matter.
But what about just a
number of gains and losses?
What if the stock
market goes up a lot?
What are people going
to sell or [INAUDIBLE]??
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Well, one issue
is that you don't know when
or for how long something
has been losing.
So if it's been
losing for long time
or gaining for a long time, that
might impact the [INAUDIBLE]
hang onto it or sell it?
FRANK SCHILBACH: So
he does have that.
I think I'm asking for
something very basic, which
is, if the stock
market goes up a lot,
you'll have lots of winners.
So you're going to realize
lots of-- if you just
sell randomly, stocks,
gains and losses,
and you just don't care, you'll
have much more realized gains
compared to realized losses just
because your stock market went
up a lot.
Similarly, if the
stock market went down,
you will find that people
have way more realized losses
compared to realize gains.
And it looked like I'm really
trying to sell the losers,
but it's not I'm actually
selling the losers.
I just have a lot more losers.
That's all I was asking.
I think he has actually the
information about the purchase
prices.
So what he then does is
something very simple.
It just looks at people's
portfolios and says,
how many losing
stocks do you have?
What's your propensity to
sell the losing stocks, which
is what you call the PLR, the
Proportion of Losers Realized?
The same he does for
the PGR, which is
a Proportion of Gains Realized.
So he looks at each person
when they sell something.
They look at how many
losing stocks do you have.
How many winning
stocks do you have?
And then he looks at what's
the probability of you
selling any of those depending
on they're winners or losers.
So what the main
finding then here
is that the PGR, the
Proportion of Gains Realized,
is larger than the PLR.
And that's to say that's what
they call the disposition
effect, which is a tendency
to sell winners and hold on
to losers.
Does that make sense?
OK.
And so why do we
care about that?
Or why is this actually bad?
Is it's necessarily
suboptimal behavior?
Why do we care?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I think
you had mentioned
in a previous class
[INAUDIBLE] sometimes it
might be worthwhile to
hold on to the winners
or someone who's
betting on [INAUDIBLE]..
But probably shouldn't
be an overall bias
towards selling losers.
And then probably [INAUDIBLE]
overall effective strategy
[INAUDIBLE].
FRANK SCHILBACH: Right.
So it depends on,
essentially, how well
the winners and the
losers are going to do.
It turns out, so in
principle, you would say,
well, winners and losers
should have the same expected
return regardless of the
winners and losers in the past.
That's essentially the
efficient market hypothesis,
just to say past price
changes should just not
be predictive of future momentum
or price changes overall.
Because the current price should
have incorporated essentially
all information that's
available at this point in time.
So to that degree, it shouldn't
matter actually what you sell.
You could just
randomly sell stuff.
Now, you should not sell a lot.
Usually, there's commissions
involved in these trades.
So essentially,
you shouldn't sell
anything that's essentially
leading to over-trading.
Odean has another
paper that shows
essentially, in
particular, men tend
to be overconfident in how
good they are at trading.
And they tend to over-trade,
and that's really costly.
It turns out that, in
their specific period,
in fact there's momentum.
And that used to be the case
quite a bit in that period
of time, which essentially
has to do with the winner
is actually doing
better than the losers
by quite a big margin.
That is to say, you should
have actually did exactly
then the opposite.
If anything, you should
have sold the losers
and keep the winners because
they are, in fact, making
more money in the short and
medium run in that period, OK?
There's also the
investors sell more losers
and winners in December.
This is what you see here.
Why is that?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Is it
that you can count
your losses toward your income?
FRANK SCHILBACH: Exactly,
this is for tax reasons.
So that actually happens to--
Jim Poterba, who's in
the economics department,
actually did a paper on this.
So there you can
essentially realize losses,
and that reduces
your taxes overall.
Exactly.
But overall, essentially
what's happening
is that people do seem to
engage in this behavior.
In a pretty striking
fashion, they
seem to be losing quite
a bit of money from that.
OK.
Let me mention at least the
marathon running and perhaps
the golf example,
and then we're going
to move towards
prices and firms.
How do firms react
to these biases?
But what I'm trying to
do here is essentially
show you a bunch of
different settings.
And essentially, if you
look at different settings
in the world, there's lots
and lots of different settings
where reference-dependence
seems to matter.
One way or the other, it seems
to be important in shaping
people's behavior.
So this is a very nice paper
about a marathon running
finishing times.
These are many, many marathons.
They have lots of data on
finishing times for people.
So the law of
large numbers would
predict that, if you look at
essentially people's finishing
times, if people have different
talents and so on and so forth,
the finishing times should
look something like this.
OK.
Some people are faster.
Some people are slower.
But overall they're should be
some smooth distribution that
essentially is like log normal
or whatever you want it to be.
But essentially, it should
look something like this.
So why might it
not look like this?
Or what might people do instead?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: They may
say, I'll beat 4:30.
And then you might see
bunching at certain points,
like 4 hours, 4:30,
5 hours, 5:30.
FRANK SCHILBACH: Right.
So exactly as you
say, it might be
that people have
reference points
not in terms of status
quo here and the like.
Reference points might
be goals or aspirations.
You might say, I really want
to run the marathon in 4 hours
or 4:30 or 4 hours if you want.
And then what the marathon
times actually look like
is something like this.
And in particular,
it seems like people
have lots of goals of
reaching something like--
if you look at the
distribution, what you see
is exactly as you predict.
If you look at the
half hour or even
the quarter hour sort
of points, there's
essentially bunching from below.
So essentially,
people seem to be,
if they're at pace to finish
at 4 hours and 1 minute,
they try to sort of speed
up and just make it to 3:59.
So you see a bunch of bunching
at the half hour slots.
You see actually much less
at 6 hours and 30 minutes
or something.
It seems that few people
have actually goals.
Once you run the marathon
in 6 hours and 30 minutes,
which is probably
what I would do,
you know, it doesn't really
matter whether you're
like 6:31 or 6:29.
But there's very
ambitious people
who want to like finish in 4:30,
4 hours, or 3:30 and the like.
And there's a bunch of
bunching from below there.
So you see the same for quarter
hour times, a little bit less
of that.
And sort of that's consistent
with the reference point
here being a goal
and aspiration.
You want to reach 4 minutes.
You want to brag to
your friends and so on.
And it's not so great
if you do that and say,
I finished in 4 hours and 1
minute as opposed to if you
say I finished below 4 hours.
Now, when you look at the effort
at the end of the race, what
would you expect?
So what we have here on
the x-axis is people.
These are the 40 kilometer pace.
These are in 30
second increments.
So the marathon is
42.195 kilometers.
So what I'm showing you
here is, essentially,
the 40 kilometer pace people
are ranked or distributed
by the 40 kilometer pace,
the first 40 kilometers.
Now, what you would
expect for people--
so there are some
people who were at pace
to reach 3:55 and some people
at pace to reach 4:05 and so on.
What is it that you
would expect people
to do when you look at how fast
people run towards the last two
kilometers of the race?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: If they're
really close,
they're going [INAUDIBLE]
especially hard.
FRANK SCHILBACH: Exactly.
And this is what you see.
So low means you're
running fast.
This is minutes per
kilometer I think
or relative minutes
per kilometer.
So what you should
expect is people
who are just below the goal or
people who are essentially just
above the goal, in fact, these
are the people who speed up,
OK?
And this is exactly
what you sort of
see is that people who are
just below the 4 minute mark
or some people who are
just above, they speed up
to just make it to that goal.
And sort of Allen et al.
Have a sort of analysis of this.
Essentially, what they
find is that everybody
gets sort of slower towards
the end of the race.
But if you're sort of
in reach of reaching
the goal by reaching
the time of 4 hours,
you're going to slow down less
or speed up a bit to just reach
that specific goal, OK?
Let me show you one more thing
of sports, which is golf.
So how does golf work?
In case you don't know, you hit
a ball with a club from a tee
into a hole.
The way this works is there's
usually 4 rounds of 18 holes.
There is very convex incentives
in the golf tournament.
So you get a bunch
of money if you win,
if you're sort of at the top.
For an average performance,
essentially you
don't make that much money.
I mean, you make good
money, but the prize money
is really in terms of
when you do really well.
So now, what is par?
Par is how many strokes,
many shots, do you need to--
how many shots a very
good golfer should require
to complete a given hole.
So par is usually
3, 4, or 5 shots.
And then eagle is 2 below par.
So if you have a par 4
hole, if you do 2 shots,
that's an eagle.
If you do 3 shots in that
case, that would be a birdie.
4 would be par.
Bogey would be 1 above par.
And double bogey would
be 2 above par, OK?
So knowing all that, so
what matters for golf
at the end of a tournament
is how many shots do you
make in total.
So how can we now look at
reference-dependent preferences
here in this setting?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: The reference
is the par [INAUDIBLE]..
FRANK SCHILBACH: Yes.
The reference is the par.
Now, suppose you are
putting, which is at the end,
you know, on the green.
What are you going to do?
What kinds of
behaviors do we expect?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Well, it depends.
So if you're under
par, then you might
try-- like, you're
shooting for birdie,
or you're shooting for
par and it's a long putt,
you might try to make sure
that you get it to the hole.
Whereas, if you are already
over par or double over par,
you might try to
play a little safer,
make sure you're not way over.
FRANK SCHILBACH: Right.
So some of this is
about risk preferences,
how risky your shots are.
Another way to
think about this is
kind of how much effort
do you put in your shot.
In some sense, to the extent
that you can sort of allocate
attention or really
focus an effort,
maybe that's sort of limited
over the course of 18 holes
and 4 rounds of each of those.
You might sort of try
particularly hard to do well
on shots that make
you reach par compared
to shots that might get you
a birdie or even better.
And so this is
exactly as you say.
The fairly obvious reference
point for each hole in golf
is reach par.
Importantly, it doesn't
matter whether you
have birdie, par, and
bogie, versus par, par, par.
Essentially, that gives
you exactly the same amount
of shots overall.
But now what Pope and
Schweitzer ask is the question,
are putters more likely
to make their par
than their birdie points, right?
So essentially, depending on
are you at possibility of losing
or at gaining,
essentially if you're
worried about losing par, are
you going to behave differently
compared to when you can make
a birdie, which is in the gain
domain potentially?
The same you could say about
bogies, where you're already
in the loss domain because
you're already doing terribly.
And you're trying to
avoid a double bogey.
So now, what they
find, essentially,
is the par putts are much
more likely to be made.
There's 2 or 3 percentage
points more likely
to be made compared to
equivalent birdie putts.
The authors rule out a bunch
of different explanation.
It doesn't have to do with
the heterogeneity of player
ability.
They even have sort of
like GPS information
of exactly where the ball
is compared to the hole.
And they do all
sorts of comparison
of how hard the shot is.
They don't think it
has to do with learning
from earlier putts.
And it seems to
also not have to do
with hole specific preferences.
Some holes are really
hard, and some holes
are really simple
and easy and so on.
So it doesn't seem to
do with any of that.
So again, that's sort of another
instance of reference-dependent
that seems to be in
quite a few settings.
Let me sort of skip the Deal
or No Deal TV show, which
we can do briefly in recitation,
and talk a little bit
about prices and firms.
So one fact that
we see in the world
is that demand often
responds more strongly
to price increases than to
price decreases of frequently
purchased items.
And we already discussed
this last time.
That's to say, so usually
people have a reference point
in terms of either
the price they pay
or the expenditures
on certain items.
So now, as something
becomes more expensive,
what they tend to
do is essentially
reduce how much the, for
example, gasoline or the like.
They tend to then sort of
just reduce their expenditures
because they have a budget for,
say, gasoline or certain items.
And so what they
tend to do is then
the reference point is
either the past price
or the past expenditures.
And people tend to
sort of be loss averse
then over their expenditures
over the specific domain.
Now, that then leads to--
so if a firm knows this,
so essentially if you
know that essentially people
react a lot to price increases
compared to price decreases,
that leads to sticky prices,
essentially.
So raising your price
above a past price
is very costly because you
lose a lot of customers
from doing that.
So now, lowering your
price below the past price
won't actually do very much.
Essentially, you're
not going to generate
a lot more extra demand.
Plus, raising the price
in the future is costly.
You know, essentially,
once you lower the price,
it's hard to get up any more.
So for these frequently
purchased items,
you see a lot of price
stickiness and price
equalization across markets,
across time and products.
Now, that's sort of one thing
about prices in the world
that you would see.
But more generally,
I want to sort of ask
the question in the
last few minutes
about, if you were
a company, suppose
you did an internship
somewhere in the summer.
You took behavioral economics.
Hopefully, you
learned something.
But what can we learn about
the firm policies and so on now
that you know about
loss aversion?
What would you tell
them they should do?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: You could start with
having a really high price
and then lowering them.
Because people will
feel like, oh, I'm
getting [INAUDIBLE] deal.
FRANK SCHILBACH: Right.
So that was what previously
was mentioned is I say,
you could sort of, in particular
when you introduce a price,
new product and so on, you might
want to start at a high price
and then sort of lowering them.
And people really
like having deals,
and they feel good about it.
Notice that that doesn't work
so well for products that you
already have and so on.
Because then essentially, once
you start with a high price,
people get really upset.
And you will lose the customers.
But once you introduce a new
product, be it like an iPhone
or be it like some whatever,
new computer or whatever,
it makes a lot of sense to
start with a really high price.
That sort of sets
the reference point.
And then people sort
of feel like they
get good deals overall.
What else could you do?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: You could
offer [INAUDIBLE] price.
You could offer a
temporary discount.
That was you keep
your reference point.
[INAUDIBLE] offer
discounts when you
want to lower the price
temporarily [INAUDIBLE]..
FRANK SCHILBACH: Exactly.
That's what a lot of
companies tend to do.
They tend to do, essentially,
these special occasions
with Black Friday and the like.
Exactly as you say,
it's temporary.
It's not a thing that prices
are permanently lower.
It's just, right now,
you get this great deal.
And then things
go back to normal.
And somehow you have to hope
that people don't sort of
adjust their reference point
towards the temporarily
lowered price.
What else?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Kind of down that
line, you have free trials.
So companies sends you--
FRANK SCHILBACH: Yes.
AUDIENCE: --for [INAUDIBLE]
and then take it away,
people will feel more
compelled to get it back
because it's loss aversion.
And that's what [? creates ?]
[INAUDIBLE] people value it
at higher price than otherwise.
FRANK SCHILBACH: Yes.
AUDIENCE: So [INAUDIBLE].
So if you shop online,
you might have wondered.
Lots of companies have
this thing on like,
oh, you can order
whatever you want.
Essentially, it's free returns.
And you kind of wonder,
that seems like a bad deal
from the company's perspective.
Because people buy a lot
of stuff and send it back.
The hope is exactly as you say.
It might be just in part
people like to experiment.
And they like some
stuff and not others.
And that's worth doing it.
But the hope, in
particular, is to say, well,
I want you to try
it out for a while.
You get used to it.
Then the endowment
effect kicks in.
You value it more.
It essentially becomes yours.
And then essentially you become
loss averse towards that.
By the way, I should
have mentioned
this is really a fascinating
book by Cialdini who
was talking about the
psychology of persuasion.
He spend a lot of
time with salespeople,
in particular sort of car
salespeople and so on,
trying to learn what are they
actually doing in markets.
And he has these amazing
stories of salespeople, what's
all sorts of tricks they use.
It's psychologically extremely
rich and interesting in terms
of just trying to
understand what people do.
And that ranges from things,
once you purchase a car,
they let you test
drive in the car.
And you sit in it.
And it feels like yours.
Or when you try to
buy a house, then
people would say, oh, you know,
this will be your living room.
And this is where your
baby is going to sleep.
And there's lots of sort
of ways in which people
make sort of something
feel yours and really try
to sort of get the
endowment effect to kick in.
If you were to work
in an insurance firm,
what would you do, somebody
who offers insurance
in one way or the
other or products
that offer insurance
in some ways?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: We talked about this a
little bit in a previous class.
But this is why,
I think, companies
will sell things like Apple
Care or operative warranties.
Because they know they'll
make money off of it
because people tend
to over-insure.
FRANK SCHILBACH: Exactly.
There's lots of
different products
where there's extended
warranties and all sorts
of things, like Apple care,
et cetera, where people
are very risk averse, what it
looks like, presumably loss
averse where, in fact,
actually the claim
rate tends to be very low.
So you can make a lot of money
with this by saying, yes,
I'm going to exchange
it and this and that.
Because, essentially,
it doesn't happen that
often at the end of
the day even if there's
moral hazard or other
issues of people
not treating their stuff that
well once they have insurance.
What about wage
setting, like when
you set your employees' wages?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Could that be
linked to mass unemployment
in recessions because you know
that, if you lower the wage,
then morale will go down a lot?
And you can actually decide
just to kick them out?
FRANK SCHILBACH: Right.
Exactly.
So there is a large
literature on wage stickiness,
essentially exactly as you
say, where people are extremely
reluctant to lower wages.
Companies are very
Because, essentially,
workers are really unhappy.
And these are often nominal
wages or real wages.
It doesn't really
matter that much,
but usually it's nominal wages.
People really, really dislike
nominal wage reductions.
And so, now, in some times
when companies would actually
need to lower wages and sort
of to be able to keep workers
not to make losses, companies
might rather sort of fire
some workers rather
than sort of lowering
the wages for everybody.
Because, essentially,
the remaining workers,
once you lower
wages for everybody,
everybody would be unhappy.
If you just fire one
worker, everybody else
will be less unhappy than
about their wage reductions.
Similarly, firms are sort
of reluctant to hire people
at lower wages, if there's other
people who make higher wages,
because people really
dislike weight dispersion.
So essentially,
overall, you want
to avoid wage cuts
as much as possible.
And that leads to
essentially then sort
of macroeconomic inefficiencies.
And people have
argued, in particular,
it leads to unemployment
because, essentially, wages
are not going down as much
as they should in recessions.
And that's bad for firms.
And, therefore, they
hire fewer workers
or retain fewer workers overall.
I think I mentioned,
we mentioned,
all of those kinds of things.
So now, that's sort of
what firms are doing.
Now, another thing
you might think about
is what are you going to
actually do in your real lives.
I think there's many different
things that you can actually
think about is the framing of
situations, for example, can
make a big difference.
If you present something
to your friends,
different options, whether you
present that as gains or losses
makes a big difference
potentially.
Managing people's expectations
is really important.
If there's some big goal
that they could reach
or some lower goal
they could reach,
if you sort of oversell
the high chance
of reaching some
big goal, they might
reach the other goal that's
actually pretty good,
might feel really
disappointed about that,
be it in job search or the like.
So managing people's
expectations,
including your own expectations,
seems really important.
There's something about
aggregating losses and gains,
which essentially is to
say, since people seem
to be risk averse over gains--
so since value function is
concave over gains and convex
over losses, what
you should do is
potentially be really careful
about when you give people
a positive or negative
feedback or bonuses and so on.
You might want to sort
of be careful whether you
aggregate the losses or--
so aggregating losses makes
sense because essentially it's
convex in the loss
domain, as opposed to you
want to give small
increments of gains overall.
Now, one thing that
I do want to mention
is you want to be
kind of very careful
with loss-framed incentives.
There's a company who
was trying to do this.
These are car
manufacturers who were
trying to give essentially
their car dealers incentives,
sort of targets for their
sales of their cars.
What essentially happened
in the end of the day
is there was a bunch
of multitasking.
The company or the
car salespeople
were essentially selling certain
cars, but then not others
and were essentially
multitasking
and then sort of reverting,
sort of reallocating efforts
to one thing versus
the other, which then
seemed like a really good idea.
There was recently a valuation
that sort of showed that that
was actually a pretty bad idea.
And the company would
have lost a lot of money
overall if this had been scaled.
We're going to have
this, the Deal or No Deal
and this specific
paper in recitation
to tell you in more
detail because I
want to move towards social
preferences next time.
So as I said, next time we
talk about social preferences.
Bring your laptop.
And I'll send you
further instructions.
Thank you.